we have Magnus Carlson's most incredible
moments as world champion this one right
here is vishwanathan with the white
pieces versus Magnus Carlson in 2013.
here we go so this is a Nims on Indian
same as variation right and the last
move here was B3 from Magnus just saying
hey man I'm trying to clean this pawn
and of course Anan is saying I'm trying
to make your king cool you can get your
little queen I'm just gonna try to
Checkmate you right so of course this is
a hints to move uh F5 B3 and he's like
cool well if it's one of the non says
hey okay you can get this queen I'm
gonna try to go for me so he goes Queen
F4 you get another piece in the game
this looks very very dangerous here four
black but Black's actually better wow
okay well let's see what happens in fact
black to move what did Magnus play in
this position
nicely nice C7 what the heck is going on
night disease every thought it'd be
something spectacular it was like yeah
I'm waiting for this one oh it's
something spectacular but it's just
Knight to C7 defensive move cool allows
F6 to happen here F6 is going to take on
G7 it's gonna be kind of annoying scary
things happening with Knight H5 what do
you do in this position
Magnus plays G6 okay it's locked up it's
gonna be scary if a queen gets to H6
also if the queen and a rook get to the
H file it's gonna be a wrap for black
here Magnus is going to be mated Okay
cool so Magnus understands that vicious
understands that too and plays Queen to
H4 where is he going class eight six
right he's about to make he's also
trying to get the Rook over here too as
well okay cool with that being said your
move what do you do now it's black to
move
[Music]
here's the move hence Knight C7 to put
the Knight on EA the saying goes a
knight on E8 is actually f8 the x is
what they say there is no mate right so
usually depending on where this Knight
is if a knight on f8 or E8 it does
control some very key squares that can
stop you from getting mated now a knight
understands this he said oh there's no
mermaid that's cool I'm gonna put my
queen right here what I'm trying to do
is bring the Rook up to F3 or F4 and
actually go for this manual eight seven
because you stop the G7 made that's cool
perfect well Magnus understands this so
what does Magnus do in this position
black to move
here it is Magnus says cool you want
mate okay that's cool that's cool go for
it me too do your thing big fella go
ahead if it's Jonathan and on do it so
he says okay I will Young fella Rook F4
he goes here and he's going for Rook H4
mate wow this is scary why are you gonna
get your queen you did all of this are
you gonna get your queen or not of
course we are B1 Queen right after B1
Queen Knight to F1 from Hanan and the
move the move here that seals the deal
is what guys there's two Queens on the
board Magnus has two queens but is he
getting mated or not it's black to move
he goes
cleaning one and then the game's over
the game ended right here believe it or
not there is no more PGN right what do
you mean Queenie what how what what what
what sense does that make well let's see
what happens the idea here you have to
Queen E1 where were you putting your
Rook H4 well I can just go Rook H4 but
guess what after I capture it Queen
sacrifice sacrificing one of my two
queens after Queen takes H4 let's do a
peace count you have a queen you have a
bishop and a knight I have a queen a
bishop a knight and a rook guys so after
that this is done right I have an extra
piece an extra rook and there's no mate
here so that's a resignation and Magnus
wins that's incredible right let's move
to the next one okay guys here we are
with our next one most incredible moment
for Magnus Carlson as world champion now
this one that everyone has seen before
does this bring back memories here
feeling like we're going down memory
lane here as this is Magnus Carlson
versus Sergey kariakin in 26 scene all
right here we go so last move was
actually Rook A7 from uh Sergey here and
Rook A7 is just really annoying feels
kind of menacing but we are up in
exchange here and our King is definitely
kind of weak Magnus sees the danger and
it just understands that I can do a lot
of things here because you're only doing
it with the rook and my pieces are very
close to my king so let's see what
happens after Rick A7 well what do you
do in this position right you played
Magnus here what do you do in this
position
here it is right I mean I smell the
danger but it's a paper tiger is what
they call it we just take one at four
Queen F4 allow the check to happen Okay
cool he checked some Rook A2 whose King
is unsafe here you gotta be very careful
right King G1 you could be done King F1
you could be done as well I mean King G1
is very scary boom mate King H1 and then
you get made it on G2 ouch okay King F1
me okay can't block with a rook why did
we take this Pawn again okay wait a
second hold on we do have a king move
that is safe King H1 perfect so we go
King H1 it's very scary here because we
understand that the mate was like all
around our king and the queen just
snapped a little Pawn right Queen F2
from Sergey saying hey this is mate
right and cool you can trade queens or
you can try you know Queen G3 is also a
movie after Queen G3 I'm just gonna
maybe move away get the rook and there's
there's some problems you have to try to
figure out how you're gonna make your
king save while trying to attack Black's
King at the same time but Magnus has
another thing in mind in fact a very
very good move in this position but it's
up to you to figure now what is White's
move in this position
foreign
[Music]
easy right you have two moves King H7 or
Bishop f8 really only one of them looks
very good of course Bishop f8 the
problem with that one is I can actually
sacrifice The Rook The Rook Hey
sacrifice no rook and then after King
takes Rook F7 right Rook F7 and then I
can go Rook at eight and bring the queen
in as well a very nasty line Sergey
smells the blood in the water then said
you're not about to get me ha ha King H7
happens and this is a Legendary game a
legendary move from a legendary player
you are gonna make this move right now
it's right to move what did magnets do
in this position
incredible moment from the world
champion incredible when it happened it
shook the world here it is white to move
plague
we ain't shits oh my goodness incredible
resignation on the spot getting off the
board Queen H6 what a move that's
disgusting it can be captured twice well
let's see what happens if Pawn takes
Rook F7 made
and if King takes well of course Rook h
a check and made beautiful that was a
sick and wicked combo and an incredible
moment from an incredible player the
world champion Magnus cross okay guys
here we go with the next one most
incredible moments from world champion
Magnus cross and this one is actually a
very very famous One In fact when it
made history right as the longest game
in world championship history lasting 7
hours and 47 minutes one game right okay
cool white pieces is Magnus Crossing
black pieces of Zion palniacci in 2021.
all right check this out last move was
King to G7 from Beyond here and then
after Rook to D2 just defending E2 maybe
something like Queen to D1 right maybe
even doubling the Rooks um on the D file
here and then Rook to ca happens now of
course a lot of you is like wait a
second can't I just well of course you
can what do you mean well it's right to
move of course try to figure it out what
did Magnus play in this position
foreign
yes you can in fact but you also can
move the queen but he says this is why
you also have this in mind of course
when you play Rook D2 you have to you
have to ask yourself am I going to give
up the queen for the two Rooks and he
goes for IT world championship match why
not game six I'm tired of these draws
let's go Queen takes CA Rook takes Rook
takes CA and here we go and when it
happened it was like it's probably a
draw here but of course there's a lot of
moves in fact we're on move 27 and this
move went literally a hundred more moves
right all right so we're gonna fast
forward in fact because we're not gonna
be here to talk about 100 more moves so
here after a queen E4 Queen H4 check is
a thing it also opens up the H file he
makes the decision Magnus that is to
sacrifice back really just trying to
play for a win draw after draw after
draw game six you know what whatever
sack the queen give the Rook back Rook
takes and he's saying at this point it's
very hard for you to win especially if
you end up taking my Rook here right and
I have a rook in the night versus the
pawn versus the pieces and and my pawns
are nice with a good structure still
could still be drawn but it's practical
and it's a human element okay Rook takes
A3 Queen H4 check King G1 Queen E4 right
and shuffling shuffling some more six
hours seven hours am somebody's about to
blunder some of the queen G6 Rick F7
nothing happens still you still can't
take it dude tonight G7 being just
winning at five Queen G1 and Knight G7
still winning we're gonna walk the King
around E7 is also on top and Queenie and
Magnus wins incredible whole world went
crazy here and it's actually made young
crack in fact in a way after all of the
pressure all the game all the hours of
playing there that was incredible let's
move to the next one here we are with
the next one of Magnus Carlson's
incredible moments as world champion
this one is 2018. of course that's
fabulous Fabiano of course when you play
Favi in 2018 here this was the rapid the
rapid tie breaks of course because they
drew all the classical games the opening
here was actually expression of Sicilian
and of course there was not a loss with
this fast across Sicilian from the black
side of course with uh with Magnus
playing it you know so just to put that
out there if you like especially called
Sicilian definitely check it out
definitely stroking very well in 2018
and still to this day very strong
opening right okay so Bobby's playing
white and tie breaks here last move Rook
to C1 he's putting some pressure here
what he wants to do is probably play
Push with C5 use the bishop in the night
and do uh whatever damage he can down
the C file here so of course uh Magnus
chooses Bishop takes E2 and after Queen
takes he understands that this queen is
a misplaced so he goes Queen to F5 just
puts on a nice diagonal here maybe play
E4 right uh the light squares are kind
of weak for white here so we just want
to do something with it maybe even put a
knight on E5 but Bobby says I gotta move
fast here and he plays C5 immediately
this is a very strong move but of course
it does hand the initiative to Black
slightly but how Okay is okay it's black
to move what do you do in this position
you're playing as Magnus what do you do
okay the move here after C5 is don't
worry about it look gang safety chat
Castle the King get the king out the
center what you're going to take the
pawn activate my Bishop Bobby says no
I'm gonna play C6 actually I want to
pass Pawn all right past pawns must be
pushed so okay we must push it without
if he's pushing a pass Pawn he's hitting
B7 there's only kind of one right move
here to do right and that's take on C6
so we take on C6 he takes back now we
can play D5 at some point right but the
D5 square is opened up maybe we go E4
right now which is a possible move but
of course Magnus had another thing in
mind which also was the number one move
on the engine let's see if you can find
it at home black to move what did
magnets do in this position
the move here is Rook F to ca very nice
because you want to be able to even tuck
the bishop on f8 if you can it also
attacks this and this Rook is defending
this pawn it also can go up to maybe A5
light goes Queen to C4 he wants to
defend it push it also as well put
Knight on D5 here okay so and remember
you know this uh he wants to put
pressure on A4 as well everything on a C
file that's what we talked about before
uh Magnus plays Bishop to d8 we can also
use this for Bishop A5 and Etc you see
this a lot in the night or Sicilians or
even just his Pawn structure period with
the bishop on E7 right the pawn
structure is a same as many Sicilians
but the themes and ideas are definitely
the same Rook after C8 but you've seen a
lot of Sicilians move the Bishop from E7
to d8 because it's a very bad piece and
it goes over to this side of the board
right Fabi understands this he says 95.
time to push the pawn to C7 right put
the Knight on a very good Square you got
some problems you got some things you
need to answer here Magnus and you got
some things you gotta answer to chat
what is it black to move
okay the move here is E4 E4 right put
the pawn on e4 remember we talked about
the light Square weaknesses and we would
love what kind of piece to go there
raise your hand I'm sure you got some
ideas already I'm sure you're already
thinking about it C7 happens
right so we're just gonna move the
bishop I mean you can but the best move
is just take it which he did he take
capture it Knight takes C7 and then 95
with Tempo attacking the queen and D3
and F3 squares are very weak as well
right and then afabi loves to calculate
he loves tactics too as well so he goes
for a tactic but it doesn't work the
move Harry play was Knight D5 whoa relax
you're gonna have to relax my brother
Knight D5 is a very real wild move right
and you take my queen
I take yours right oh that's crafty from
fabulous Bobby here now of course 95
actually has a a problem to it it
doesn't work why doesn't it work black
to move
the movie play here is very simple now
you have two ways of doing this but the
move he chose which is good you could
play King f8
but he just wanted to get out of all
type of checks and Etc so he played King
H7 and the game
well why is it over well let's see the
queen first off is defending this Rook
this Rook is defending Israel which is
hitting the queen so if you move the
queen somewhere we also have Knight D3
check on tap right of course so all your
threats are done everything you had is
now gone right so 93 is going to come
and with Tempo checking I'm also going
to pick up some material the Knight is
here what a move just King H7 side step
and have a nice day and I'm still World
Champ here that was nice even taking it
to Fabi in that game very tactical
towards in there with his Chestnut Grove
Sicilian that was incredible let's move
to the last one here we are with our
last incredible moment from Magnus
Carlson as the World Champ this one is
Magnus Carlson versus vishwanathan anat
in 2014. okay Max is playing white here
and this is a crazy one let's see what
happens see if you guys remember this in
fact Rook D to G8 was the last move from
vishwanathan anat after Rook D to GA
here it is King to D2 what is this move
right here now this one was a very very
crazy you know a thing the internet blew
up about this afterwards because it was
an oversight that happened right here
there was an oversight for both sides
missed by Magnus and by Anon in this
position right here it's black to move
in fact Magnus playing white but it's
black to move in this position and black
missed something incredible what is it
black to move
in the game Anan plays A4 but he
actually missed they both missed this
1965 and this could have changed the
trajectory of the whole Tournament of
the whole match effect Knight takes C5
right after Knight takes E5 whoa what is
going on right of course those pieces
drop off but that's the problem here
loose pieces drop off the Rook is very
loose so after the move Knight takes E5
here which is just winning a pawn after
Rook takes in between move it'd be nice
if there was a check but there's no
check but there's a check for black
though and I take C4 boom he missed this
but he's like wait I just step up on the
game on the night right and then he goes
Knight B2 another in-between track wow
now the king is too far away to attack
it King has to move somewhere
we take we're up a clean Pond here right
now of course there's still some
Precision from black but that was
definitely a huge oversight and g2's
hanging too even if you take H6 huge
oversight from both of them they missed
it it didn't happen in the game right
and also if Rook takes E5 then we would
do Rook takes G4 completely winning for
black definitely missed by both of them
after King D2 and Nam plays A4 Magnus
didn't give him a second chance King E2
and says now if you take it there is no
checks anymore it was really bad it was
a very very smooth and cruising wind for
magnets after that oversight from both
of them that's incredible and these were
an incredible moments from the world
champion Magnus cross hopefully you
enjoyed this video and if you did then
make sure you guys watch the ones right
after this we'll see you on the next one
good
[Music]